Let's put this distributed object model of Java
to work. And, the example that I'm going to
construct is ,a bank account server. And, the server
has obvious API's for accessing your bank account, you
can deposit, you can withdraw, and you can ask
for a balance. So, those are the API's that
the server is going to provide as a service.
Now, the question is. How best to implement it
using Java. In particular, given that ,there is the remote object and the remote
interface available as mechanisms in the distributed object model, what
would be the best way to construct this service as a distributional
object, accessible from clients anywhere in
the network? Let's consider two possibilities.